trying to ask a question and the teacher
would forget and all the substitutes
didn't know
they'd be like clark and he used to be
like
[Laughter]
hey remember the teacher wouldn't call
on you you'd have to do this you'd have
to use the post like this
oh
dude after 15 minutes like this and
brenda's question was always like oh
is it launched yet i was always can i go
to the bathroom can i go to the bathroom
trying to see my boys chill a little bit
talk [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
hallway dog dude you see a girl maybe
show my outfit act like i'm
[ __ ] sharp my pencil to show off my
fit you feel me
yeah i would do that that would be the
best man walking up to the pencil
sharpener everybody
see you yeah yeah what's going on new
kicks you stupid [ __ ]
they're like why are you sharpening
seven pounds i'd always go up there and
raise hell
man dude the best was when you got out
of class during class and you got to go
walk in the hall
and there was always like some [ __ ]
weirdos in there yeah it was always
strange
there was always like some kid who was
like getting called to the office for
something
and he's like i don't know man i don't i
didn't do it
you're like nah of course you didn't
sean man i'm sure everything would be
cool and you knew he was [ __ ] i think
the last time you'd ever see him at
he was school he was an idiot and then
they would send those kids to that
remember it was like the secondary
school the bad school
oh yeah got his degree that's where i
had to graduate from
yeah that's why i can't find it that's
why i can't find it
yeah i did it i did it though that was
freedom in the hallway though man
yeah oh it felt like a rebel i felt like
[ __ ] neat
man second you closed the door to that
classroom
oh dude and i come back 20 minutes later
and they're like
but the teachers were so glad that i was
gone because i've been raising such hell
in the classroom
you could tell they were low-key kind of
excited that i've been going so long
yeah they know what's up did you find
the bathroom
oh i huh i forgot i even had to go to
the bathroom but the worst you have to
give the pass
back oh come on man was this [ __ ]
russia let me live
dude and you'd see like they'd always be
like uh
they'd always be out in the hall like
some teacher would be out there like
having to deal with some personal issue
the principles not to be walking down
the hall like what are you doing out
here theo
yep the worst is if uh you came back
took too long i wouldn't let all the
girls know in class i wasn't taking a
[ __ ]
oh again it was crazy out there people
running around and stuff like what
dude i used to sneak into the mentally
challenged classroom next to our class
and steal all our candy bro
i feel bad about that and one time i
stayed in the cupboard in there and they
all came back
in and i had to do like a whole listen
to a whole lesson that they learned
about
you would steal candy from me
[Laughter]
i didn't know stuck on that i didn't i
mean i guess i knew that someone were
mentally disabled but i didn't
they weren't fully they're like forrest
gump
some of them i mean they were definitely
at least a crescent moon of a brain you
know
okay so you're not talking anybody that
was running i'll tell you what you know
in college at dal ward that was the
athletic department there's this kid
right dal ward also sounds like a
[ __ ]
place where you go to school if you need
help yeah what was where the
football team was that that's where the
weight room and stuff are and we'd go oh
yeah i remember
but there was this there's this dude
there i thought he was like 21
22 he had a twin he was actually 44 and
he had down syndrome
and he'd always wear matching sweats top
bottom same [ __ ] every day
and have him fold the towels and fix the
drinks and i thought he was touching
everybody's butt because i'd go get a
gatorade every time before practice he
always rubbed my butt i thought yeah
i'll let him
you know do his thing maybe he thinks
it's my back and i was telling the team
like how about
jerry was rubbing our asses am i right
no i wasn't right
i was getting molested bam they fired
him so there's your story
they fired him he's your favorite i
hired him that's so sad your stories
bear in mind because i didn't get steak
out of it or nothing
no aerosmith concert nothing i think if
somebody's gatorade
but if somebody has a disease or
something or a hand yeah
i felt i felt bad telling them no i
think you got to let them
touch you yeah just be nice you know
about it i was super don't make them
feel bad brandon i didn't i was super
nice
you got him fired no well he got fired
because he took all the hand towels
and put him into his sweats on his
genitals oh yeah so they had to fire him
over that
yeah damn so that's pretty sad
see i had a great high school experience
sure you did
next week you're gonna come in with a
photo of somebody else's default no i
got it i got i don't have the diploma
i don't have that oh yeah i don't have
an hour
we're getting it somewhere there we go
how would i get into college
that's what we want to know doing
backflips you're an athlete they'll
they'll pull some strings oh yeah oh
totally man
okay um what else is going on
is